(Video) Adulto: ¿Hiciste trampa? Niño: No.
Kang Lee: Y este es el segundo niño.
(Video) Adulto: ¿Hiciste trampa? Niña: No.
KL: Bien, si piensan que el primer niño está mintiendo,
levanten la mano.
Y si creen que el segundo niño miente, por favor, levanten la mano.
De hecho, el primero dice la verdad
y el segundo niño miente.
Parece que muchos son pésimos detectores de mentiras infantiles.
(Risas)
Hemos jugado los mismos juegos
con muchos, muchos adultos de toda clase.
Y les mostramos muchos videos.
Los niños mintieron en la mitad de estos videos
y dijeron la verdad en la otra mitad.
Veamos los resultados de estos adultos.
Puesto que hay tantos mentirosos que los niños que dicen la verdad,
si acierta al azar,
hay una probabilidad del 50 % de que ofrezcan la respuesta correcta.
Así que si su precisión ronda el 50 %
esto significa que son terribles detectores de mentiras infantiles.
Empecemos con universitarios y estudiantes de derecho
que por lo general, tienen poca experiencia con los niños.
No, no pueden detectar las mentiras de los niños.
Sus resultados son similares a los ofrecidos al azar.
¿Qué hay de los trabajadores sociales y los abogados de protección infantil,
que trabajan con los niños día a día?
¿Pueden detectar los adultos sus mentiras?
No, no pueden.
(Risas)
¿Qué pasa con los jueces, funcionarios de aduanas y policías
que se enfrenten a los mentirosos a diario?
¿Pueden detectar las mentiras de estos niños?
No, no pueden.
¿Qué pasa con los padres?
¿Pueden detectar las mentiras de otros niños?
No, no pueden.
¿Pueden los padres detectar las mentiras de sus propios hijos?
(Risas) (Aplausos)
Uds. pueden preguntarse
por qué estas mentiras son tan difíciles de detectar.
Permítanme ilustrarlo con mi propio hijo, Nathan.
Esta es su expresión facial cuando miente.
(Risas)
Por eso, cuando los niños mienten
su expresión facial es típicamente neutra.
Sin embargo, detrás de esta expresión neutral,
el niño experimenta muchas emociones
como el miedo, la culpa, la vergüenza
y tal vez un poco de alegría por mentir.
(Risas)
Por desgracia, estas emociones son más bien efímeras u ocultas
por lo tanto y sobre todo invisibles a simple vista.
En los últimos cinco años hemos estado tratando de encontrar
una manera de revelar estas emociones ocultas
y descubrimos algo.
Sabemos que debajo de nuestra piel facial
hay una rica red de vasos sanguíneos.
Cuando experimentamos diferentes emociones,
nuestro flujo sanguíneo facial cambia sutilmente.
Estos cambios son regulados por el sistema autónomo
que está más allá de nuestro control consciente.
Por lo cual, al observar los cambios en el flujo sanguíneo facial,
podemos revelar las emociones ocultas de las personas.
Por desgracia, estos cambios de flujo relacionados con las emociones
son demasiado sutiles para detectarse a simple vista.
Así que para ayudar a revelar estas emociones faciales,
hemos desarrollado una nueva tecnología de imagen
llamada "imágenes ópticas transdérmica".
Para ello, usamos una grabadora normal
para grabarles mientras experimentan estas emociones ocultas diversas.
Y luego, con nuestra tecnología de procesamiento de imágenes,
podemos extraer imágenes transdérmicas de cambios en el flujo sanguíneo facial.
Al observar estas imágenes transdérmicas,
podemos ver fácilmente los cambios en el flujo sanguíneo facial
asociados con las diversas emociones ocultas.
Y usando esta tecnología
podemos revelar emociones ocultas relacionadas con la mentira
y por lo tanto detectar mentiras.
Podemos hacerlo de manera no invasiva,
de forma remota, a bajo costo,
con una precisión de aproximadamente un 85 %
que es mucho mejor que el azar.
Y además, descubrimos un efecto Pinocho.
No, no este efecto Pinocho.
(Risas)
Este es el efecto Pinocho real.
Cuando la gente miente,
el flujo sanguíneo facial disminuye en las mejillas
y aumenta en la nariz.
Por supuesto, la mentira no es la única situación
que revela nuestras emociones ocultas.
Entonces nos preguntamos,
además de detectar mentiras,
¿cómo más se puede emplear nuestra tecnología?
Una aplicación es en la educación.
Por ejemplo, con esta tecnología podemos ayudar a este profesor de matemáticas
identificar al estudiante en su clase con altos niveles de ansiedad
sobre el tema que imparte y así poder ayudarle.
También puede usarse en el cuidado de la salud.
Por ejemplo, todos los días hablo con mis padres por Skype,
que viven a miles de kilómetros.
Haciendo uso de esta tecnología
no solo puedo averiguar lo que está pasando en sus vidas
sino también monitorizar a la vez su ritmo cardíaco, su nivel de estrés,
su estado de ánimo y si están o no experimentando dolor.
Y quizás en el futuro,
el riesgo para un ataque al corazón o hipertensión.
Y Uds. se preguntaran:
¿podemos usarla también para revelar las emociones de los políticos?
(Risas)
Por ejemplo durante un debate.
Bueno, la respuesta es sí.
Con la ayuda de imágenes televisadas
podemos detectar el ritmo cardíaco de los políticos,
su estado de ánimo y el estrés,
y quizás en el futuro, si nos están mintiendo o no.
También podemos usarla en la comercialización de la investigación,
por ejemplo, para averiguar
si a la gente le gusta o no determinados productos de consumo.
Incluso podemos usarla en las citas.
Así, por ejemplo,
si su cita le sonríe,
esta tecnología puede ayudar a determinar si le cae bien de verdad
o si solo está tratando de ser amable con Ud.
Y en este caso, es solo una muestra de amabilidad.
(Risas)
La tecnología de imagen óptica transdérmica
está en una fase muy temprana de desarrollo.
Aparecerán muchas nuevas aplicaciones desconocidas en la actualidad.
Sin embargo, una cosa que sé con certeza
es que la mentira nunca será la misma.
Muchas gracias.
(Chino) Xie Xie.
(Aplausos)